we received some very interesting news
over the weekend Donald Trump's latest
former national security adviser is in
negotiation to testify in Donald Trump's
impeachment inquiry and if he does this
is testimony that could completely blow
up Donald Trump Boulton to be clear is a
disgusting neocon Warhawk from the era
of george w bush he was regularly at
odds with Donald Trump during his tenure
as national security adviser but he may
indeed be just a major player in
exposing how bad the corruption is under
Donald Trump Bolton's lawyers and of
course everyone associated with Donald
Trump seems to end up needing lawyers
even Trump's own lawyers making
attorneys get attorneys the alternate
interpretation for Magga boltons lawyers
say they're talking to the committee's
that are involved in the impeachment
inquiry and that john bolton may indeed
be deposed it is alleged that during
Bolton's time as national security
adviser he would regularly criticize
Rudy Giuliani for Rudy's efforts to dig
up dirt on Biden and he would call them
drug deals he would call what Rudy
Giuliani was doing drug deals he would
encourage staffers at the National at
the NSA to report this stuff to
administration lawyers it's unclear if
those reports ever actually took place
so far it's been mostly not very well
known diplomats who have been testifying
as part of this impeachment inquiry but
this would very quickly change if John
Bolton were to testify and it is really
important to remember that truly
horrible people like John Bolton can be
useful in a fight against Donald Trump's
corruption and self enrichment and
pedaling influence for his own benefit
Bolton is disgusting I mean this this
was one of the architects of the Iraq
war Bolton represents the worst of the
neoconservative impulses of the last
several decades of American foreign
policy but listen if he's useful then
have him testify why not there are
people hoping that this will be an open
door testimony but it wouldn't be that
part of this is actually about
preventing witnesses from core
their stories and if these testimonies
were in open republic you could have a
witness come in and say something and
then you could have other witnesses hear
that and then go in and tell the same or
a very similar story to make it seem as
though everything is on the up-and-up so
that's not the way that it's going to
happen the really interesting thing here
is that the instincts that are natural
to john bolton for which we are
disgusted by him right I mean his
bloodthirsty take-no-prisoners
reactionary nature that may be what
ultimately leads him to show up and to
take down Donald Trump bolton in the end
is total pond scum i mean the guys have
complete bloodthirsty bottom-feeder
but he will do what he sees as patriotic
and it just might be like we might just
happen to overlap in that he will see
denouncing and exposing what Donald
Trump has done as the patriotic thing to
do his values are counter to most of our
values in my audience would be my guests
but they might overlap in that we all
think Donald Trump should be held
accountable we all think hopefully of
john bolton does we all believe that
there should be consequences to actions
taken by presidents of the United States
and in fact it actually sort of
stunningly shows us how bad things have
gotten that in the Trump
administration's current and former
staffers someone is antithetical to my
values and to what I believe are
American values as John Bolton might end
up being a sort of de facto good guy and
I use that term I mean it's like painful
to use it about Bolton but he may end up
serving the role of a good guy in this
particular very narrow set of
circumstances by showing up and just
telling the truth about what he saw and
to be clear he's not a good guy
he may play one in this fiasco involving
the Donald Trump administration of
course I'll keep you posted on the
latest news about John Bolton's
testimony
we also are that there's a bigger list
of people again listen I mean we've been
talking about in the end if Democrats
don't enforce subpoenas this is all just
BS that that's the reality there are
higher level people that have been had
documents subpoenaed and who may be
subpoenaed personally to testify we'll
get into it if and when it looks like
they actually might otherwise the story
I'm going to have to keep telling you is
that spineless Democrats refuse to
actually attempt to enforce the
subpoenas now every time I say that
people email me and say David come on
you know it is not ultimately up to
Democrats whether the subpoenas are
enforced Trump controls this that and
the other thing and are you really going
to see the sergeant-at-arms of the house
go and hold people in contempt I'm not
there yet
all I'm saying is let's at least see
Democrats try to enforce the subpoenas
and then if they try and our stonewalled
then we'll deal with that we'll cross
that bridge when we come to it but a
priori saying it doesn't matter if
Democrats try to enforce them because
it's not going to be you know it's not
gonna be Nancy Pelosi personally going
and slapping the cuffs on anyone what
depends is whether the systems in place
will do it let's see the Democrats try
first and then see how far we get
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka is a
great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS Jobs and there is
a great new book of BS Jobs by David
Graeber
which I listened to on bling cos they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube
I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you'd like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa k mas